moi je relève que la commission
d'instruction a retenu comme infraction
la mise en danger d'autrui - la plainte
que j'avais déposée elle ne retenait pas
ces sept motifs de poursuite elles
étaient fondées sur l'abstention de
prendre des mesures pour combattre un
sinistre mais la cour de justice de la
république la commission d'instruction a
retenu ce motif je rappelle que la mise
en danger d'autrui c'est le fait
d'exposer directement autrui à un risque
immédiat de mort ou de blessure de
nature a entraîné une mutilation et
c'est pour comprendre exposées dans le
sens de
d'impliquer
de de mettre la personne en situation
bon
dans le cas de monsieur en bonis il
vient aux urgences où ils appellent le
115 est dit je suis gravement malade
j'ai beaucoup de fièvre venait me
chercher on refuse on met sa vie en
danger ce n'est pas une politique
d'ensemble qui est qui doit être
considérée c'est l'acte précis
la réponse négative qui lui a été
apportée quand il a demandé des secours
et donc je me répète au départ la
planète elle vise le samu elle vise le
chr mais si les médecins si le système
de santé n'a fait qu'appliquer des
consignes qui ont été données par le
ministère il semble tout de même normal
de demander au ministre de rendre des
comptes moi je me souviens quand même
que madame busin elle a fait des
déclarations tout de même assez
étonnante elle a déclaré qu'elle savait
qu'elle était la gravité de la situation
elle savait qu'on allait dans le mur je
crois que c'était les propos qu'elle a
qu'elle a tenus et puis dans cette
affaire il ya quand même une chose
étrange dès le début on nous a dit on ne
peut pas soigner les gens ou alors quand
vraiment ils sont aux portes de la mort
on les hospitaliser on les met sous
oxygène on les un tube mais avant on
peut rien faire prenez du doliprane
restez chez vous mais c'est écrit youth
comment est il possible de re de dire à
une personne qui est quand même
gravement malade il ya des signes
extrêmement inquiétant qu'on ne va pas
la soigner et sa manifestement ça a été
un choix ministériels un choix de santé
publique qui a été opposé aux
françaises et aux français aux habitants
de notre pays
[Musique]